I WAS TOLD TO NEVER
FOREPLAY WITH MY FOOD,
BUT I APPRECIATE
THAT HE REMEMBERED
TO WORK THE CUTIES.
THAT BANANA'S BOYFRIEND
IS NAMED WARPED BROWNLEE,
AND THE NEXT SIX MINUTES
ARE ONLY GONNA GET WEIRDER
FROM HERE.
THIS IS JUST ONE
OF WARPED BROWNLEE'S MANY
DISTURBING VIDEOS
WHERE HE TEACHES THE WORLD
HOW TO GIVE BETTER BLOW JOBS,
SO I'LL JUST WAIT A SEC WHILE
YOU GALS GO GRAB YOUR NOTEPADS.
IN TERMS OF JOBS,
BLOW FALLS SQUARELY
BETWEEN HAND AND RIM
ON THE WHORE SCALE.
AND LIKE EVERY OTHER JOB
IN THE WORLD,
MEN ARE BETTER AT IT
IN MY EXPERIENCE.
THERE'S ALWAYS ONE CHICK
IN THE FRIEND GROUP
WHO'S VERY PROUD
OF HER ORAL SKILLS,
AND SHE'S PROBABLY NOT THE ONE
WHO LOOKS GOOD NAKED.
GIRLS SEE WEENIES
LIKE KIDS SEE BROCCOLI.
THEY HOLD THEIR NOSE
AND CHOKE IT DOWN
AS LONG AS THEY KNOW
THERE'S A REWARD COMING.
THINK OF IT AS A--
SUCKING A TRIP TO WINE COUNTRY.
YOU CAN ALWAYS SLIP A PINKY
IN THE B-HOLE
WHILE YOU'RE DOWN THERE.
IT'S LIKE A CHEAT CODE
TO BEAT THE GAME FASTER.
I'VE ALREADY GONE ON RECORD
AS SAYING
LIFE BEGINS AT THE ERECTION,
WHICH MAKES SWALLOWING
CANNIBALISM IN MY BOOK.
WARPED SHOULD BE COMMITTED--
I MEAN COMMENDED.
AS OF YET, THERE'S NO LAW
AGAINST A FELLA FELLATING FRUIT
ATTACHED TO A WEIRD
DISEMBODIED TORSO.
THAT'S WHY I FLEW THAT
BANANA-SEXUAL TO HOLLYWOOD,
A CITY BUILT ON BJS,
FOR THIS WEEK'S
CE-WEB-RITY PROFILE.
[FOLKSY GUITAR MUSIC]
♪ ♪
HEY, HEY, HEY, HEY.
YOU BLOW IT, YOU BUY IT.
OH, HELLO, DANIEL.
WARPED BROWNLEE.
OH, THOUGHT
I RECOGNIZED YOU.
LISTEN.
WELCOME TO MY STAND.
EVERYTHING HERE
IS FARMED TO BUTTHOLE.
YOU'RE WELCOME TO ANYTHING.
DIDN'T KNOW WE HAD
A CELEBRITY VISITING US.
MY FIRST QUESTION IS,
WHAT THE [BLEEP]
IS ON YOUR FACE?
IT'S A CAN OF WAR PAINT.
I MEAN, SO DO YOU
DO IT YOURSELF?
- YES.
- EVERY MORNING?
NO, JUST ON MY DAYS OFF
WHEN I'M NOT WORKING.
OKAY, SO YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO WEAR SATANIC
WAR PAINT TO WORK.
NOT AT THE CEREAL FACTORY.
- AT THE CEREAL FACTORY?
- YES.
- I MAKE CEREAL.
- WHAT KIND OF CEREAL?
A LOT OF GRANOLA STUFF.
WHAT MILK DO YOU LIKE
FOR YOUR CEREAL
WHEN YOU HAVE CEREAL?
2%.
WHY NOT JUST GO TO SKIM?
I DON'T LIKE
SOFT-ASS [BLEEP].
OKAY.
- WARPED BROWNLEE.
- YES.
NOW, IS THAT YOUR GIVEN NAME?
I GOT THAT NAME
FROM MY EX-GIRLFRIEND.
SHE SAID I WAS WARPED...
BECAUSE I WANT TO HAVE SEX
WITH OTHER PEOPLE.
I LIKE THE FACT THAT SHE,
LIKE, OVERLOOKED
ALL OF THIS NONSENSE
AND WENT WITH THE FACT
THAT YOU JUST WANTED TO SLEEP
WITH OTHER PEOPLE.
YES, WE'RE STILL
FRIENDS, THOUGH.
OKAY, SO SHE IS ALIVE.
OH, SHE'S ALIVE. YEAH.
I'VE BEEN MEANING
TO ASK YOU,
WHAT'S THE STORY
ABOUT THE VIDEO
WHERE YOU WERE [BLEEP]
THAT STUFFED BEAR?
(WARPED BROWNLEE)
THE TEDDY BEAR
HAS BECOME LEGENDARY...
- SURE.
- ALL AROUND EUGENE, OREGON.
(DANIEL)
JUST BECAUSE OF THE VIDEOS?
(WARPED BROWNLEE)
'CAUSE I DO IT LIVE TOO.
THIS WEEK, ACTUALLY,
THEY'RE HAVING A MEETING
AT MY WORK ABOUT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT
INVOLVING VIDEOS,
AND I CAN'T BE THERE.
WHAT, YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO BE THERE?
- NO, 'CAUSE I'M HERE.
- OH.
SO EVERYONE
HAS TO WATCH--
GO THROUGH THIS MEETING
EXCEPT ME.
OH, WELL, THAT'S PROBABLY GOOD
THAT YOU'RE NOT THERE.
IT'LL ALLOW A LOT OF THE STAFF
THAT'S TERRIFIED OF YOU
TO SPEAK FREELY.
DID WE PAT YOU DOWN?
NO.
JESUS.
THEY SAY THIS LOOK
IS CALLED "LUMBERSEXUAL."
I THINK IT'S PRETTY SATANIC.
WHEN YOU USE THE WORD
"SATANIC,"
WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
WELL, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
WORSHIPPING THE DEVIL?
- NO.
- NO?
NOT IN A TRADITIONAL
SENSE, NO.
OKAY, SO WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
- YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND?
- NO, I DON'T.
LIKE, DOES IT MEAN COOL?
COULD MEAN, YEAH,
COOL OR THE BOMB OR--
THE BOMB?
ALL RIGHT. I GET IT.
- I DO UNDERSTAND IT.
- YEAH.
- SATANIC STYLE.
YOU WANT TO GET THAT GOING.
OH, IT'S GOING.
WHAT TIME YOU GO TO BED
AT NIGHT?
I GO LATE.
- LIKE 10:30?
- NO. NO, NO.
I GO TO BED, LIKE, AT 4:00
IN THE MORNING.
OH, OKAY.
I WORK LATE
AT THE CEREAL FACTORY.
BUT THEN I NEED TIME TO GO
TO THE BARS AFTER WORK
AND DO SOME KARAOKE,
SATANIC-STYLE.
WHAT KIND OF SATANIC-STYLE
KARAOKE SONGS ARE YOU PICKING?
I'LL DO SOME RAP SONGS
TO OPEN UP,
LOOSEN UP THE CROWD.
- SURE.
- BACK THAT ASS UP.
THEY'RE NOT GONNA
SEE THAT COMING.
- BACK THAT ASS UP?
- OH, YEAH.
- JUVENILE.
- UNCENSORED.
I WILL SAY THE WORD [BLEEP].
WELL, I MEAN, TECHNICALLY,
YOU'RE HALF BLACK.
SOME PEOPLE WOULD WATCH A VIDEO
OF YOU BLOWING A FRUIT
OR TEACHING PEOPLE
HOW TO GIVE A BLOW JOB
AND THINK THAT'S GAY.
- YOUR THOUGHTS.
- KNOW WHAT?
IF YOU LISTEN
TO THE VIDEO,
IF YOU LISTEN TO IT,
IT'S OBVIOUS I'M STRAIGHT.
- OF COURSE.
- BUT NO ONE LISTENS.
IT'S 'CAUSE THEY'RE
TOO BUSY JERKING OFF.
I SAID IN THE VIDEO--
I SAID,
"I'VE ONLY HAD 5 1/2."
I HAVEN'T GAVE 5 1/2.
I'VE NEVER GAVEN A BLOW JOB.
YET YOU TOOK TO IT
LIKE A DUCK TO WATER.
WOULD YOU CLARIFY
WHAT A HALF BLOW JOB IS?
YEAH.
WELL, IT'S WHEN THE GIRL
IS BLOWING YOU
AND SHE PASSES OUT
BEFORE SHE FINISHES.
AH, YOU DIDN'T TIME
THE MEDS RIGHT.
YEAH.
UM, HOW FAST COULD YOU GET
A GUY OFF IF YOU HAD TO?
YOU SAW THE VIDEO.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
I FINISHED
BEFORE YOU STARTED.
THE HAND IS THE KEY.
THAT'S THE MAIN PART, THE HAND.
THE GIRLS DON'T REALIZE
THAT THE HAND'S DOING
ALL THE HEAVY LIFTING.
I'VE HAD GIRLS THAT
JUST USE THEIR MOUTH,
AND IT REALLY
PISSES ME OFF.
[SCOFFS]
HOW FAR CAN YOU
TAKE THIS DOWN?
UH, MY DEEP-THROATING
SKILLS AREN'T GREAT.
- I DON'T KNOW.
- I CHALLENGE YOU.
SORRY.
I DON'T KNOW WHO WON.
HERE.
I GOT TO SELL THIS, MAN.
BJS ARE ALL WELL AND GOOD,
BUT LET ME SHOW YOU
HOW TO SATISFY A LADY.
I LIKE TO USE A POMEGRANATE
BECAUSE IT'S RED AND GROSS
AND KIND OF CONFUSING,
JUST LIKE A LADY'S
COOLIEKAI.
[GROANS]
WELL, YOU GET THE IDEA.
WARPED, THERE'S BEEN SOMETHING
I'VE BEEN MEANING TO ASK YOU.
WOULD YOU EVER CONSIDER...
FOOD PORN?
THAT'D BE REALLY
[BLEEP] SATANIC.
ALL RIGHT.
IT'S ODD THAT YOU HAD THAT
ON THE TIP OF YOUR TONGUE.
[DOORBELL RINGS]
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
♪ ♪
HELLO.
DID SOMEONE ORDER SOME
WET, JUICY FRUIT
ON A STICK?
[FUNKY ELECTRONIC MUSIC]
♪ ♪
HEY, GOLDILOCKS, YOU GONNA
TAKE THIS, OR WHAT?
FINE.
THIS IS GOING UP YOUR ASS,
ISN'T IT?
[FUNKY SENSUAL MUSIC PLAYING]
♪ ♪
[SQUISHING]
OH, GOD.
[BLENDER WHIRRING]
[SPITTING]
[DOORBELL RINGS]
WHO'S HERE?
SORRY TO BUG YOU AGAIN,
BUT THAT EDIBLE ARRANGEMENT
WAS FOR YOUR NEIGHBOR.
[GROANS]
OKAY, I AM POSITIVE
I DIDN'T GIVE YOU ANYTHING
CHOCOLATE-COVERED.
[GROANS]
GET MY MISTER OUT...
AND GOOD AS NEW.
I'M GONNA TAKE THIS
FOR MYSELF.
[APPLAUSE]
LET'S ALL PRETEND
WE DIDN'T SEE THAT
AND NEVER SPEAK OF IT AGAIN.